博 博 博 博
扩展已经是全台最大的充电网提供快充慢充家用充电还有跨品牌充电漫游服务意思就是说不管你是平常通勤假日出游甚至是临时跑远一点只要是EV Oasis的会员都比较容易找到地方补电不用一直焦虑甚几%尤其现在电动车越来越多充电这个事情跟加油一样变成日常的一部分那这样占点密度高充电速度跟整体的便利性
就会直接影响到用车体验如果说本来就是电车车主或是正在考虑入手电动车可以去了解一下EV Oasis想要看最新的站点充电费率跟活动资讯可以直接下载EV Oasis的APP来查看看以上为品牌合作资讯不构成任何投资建议有任何需要的朋友们都可以在我们资讯栏找到更多关于EV Oasis的说明与连结时间过得非常快2026就这样要过掉一半了
我相信大家应该都跟我一样是抱持着一个非常震惊的心态就连我现在讲这一段话我都觉得有一点吓到就时间也过得太快了吧在上半年不知道大家过得怎么样不管是你的生活上还是工作上我这边就简单的去做一下自己上半年的一些总结在下一集节目的时候就会进入到7月1号也就是下半年的开始跟第三季的开始
那时候我们就把它当成是一个新的开始我觉得有时候去稍微的总结一下就可以去wrap up就是大概在过去一阵子你自己的表现如果是好的话那就提醒自己不要膨胀接下来就有新的挑战如果是不好的话那就是重新的去整理一下自己的情绪然后接着还是要再去面对新的挑战那我自己的上半年我是觉得可能算是我人生的高光时刻不管是在工作
或者说在自己的生活方面我都是算是非常的喜欢也非常的感恩上天或者是不管是什么不可知的力量或者说身边的家人朋友跟工作上的同业总之就是算是收获到了一个非常好的上半年应该是在历史上会流明的不管是哪一个层面那现在讲在生活的层面就是我认为减重这个决定是非常好的
那同时在自己的体能的提升上我觉得也形成了一种那种飞轮的效应就是最早只是想说反正那时候有注意到说医师有提醒我你已经有一点点的高血压的前期所以可能要稍微注意一下自己的隐私或什么的那后来就是在对话之中得知到他跟我讲说你大概就降一公斤就可以降一毫米拱住那我说那我当然就直接用减重的方式去做处理
那本来心态其实有点类似说反正针就先打下去那接着呢反正大概能够降一点重量稍微能够过关就好就是得过且过那可是后来针打下去之后因为意识到自己的食量完全没有受到影响那时候身边还有一些大哥朋友会跟我分享说那个针打下去你甚至连运动都不想动什么信誉会变得很低之类的那妈的完全都只想当一摊烂肉之类的所以你要注意你可能会掉很多的肌肉
那结果没想到自己算是相对幸运的就是打这个针没有什么不良的副作用然后整天还是跑去运动也因为这样子那去接触了像是网球然后以及功能性或是机能性训练那这个对我的人生的改变是非常大就是一个小小的决定可是从此以后我觉得我生活形态就是就此改变因为我自己是非常喜欢现在的一个形态跟样貌那所以在身体上面我觉得是做得非常好
那在自己的家人孩子的方面孩子的身体检查各种状况也都已经是慢慢的去把它排除掉了那所以现在就是一个健康的孩子以前就会觉得说会不会这边有问题那边有一个问题那就整天会想要去跑医院或是去做更多的不管是要去获得医嘱或是你要获得second opinion反正就整天去往医院跑那在这个上半年也算是相对的去把它给解决掉了
那在工作方面呢更是非常的顺利啦那其实我相信绝大多数有去参与股票市场的人应该都比较难表现得不好那以我们的节目的气氛者来讲就绝大多数人可能是去买0050这样子的东西嘛那今年的year today都还是有个50%这个是非常吓人的数字那所以我相信绝大多数人在投资或者说在这个跟怎么讲买卖相关的方面呢
应该都还蛮不错的那至于是实体生意的话可能就比较一翻两瞪眼有些人的生活可能就没这么好那因为我自己的工作就是着重在投资方面嘛所以对我来讲我算是过了一个非常好的上半年那目前我的绩效的highlight是落在差不多4到6月那其实4到6月也是大盘一个高速爬升的时间啦所以它一定有那种beta加分的成分在里面那只是5月的那一波呢
算是我有史以来第一次感受到好像什么事情都不用做然后就可以疯狂赚钱的一段时间因为那时候手上的持股几乎都涨到进去储置股然后最恐怖的是就是过往的惯例啦就进储置股之后可能它的波动性就会降低或者说它会变成一个区间盘那可是在差不多4-5月的时候有很多储置股它反而是变成标股所以就是越观越大尾从5分钟变20分钟然后甚至是连续储置那段时间呢
因为我绝大多数有部位都是被锁在储置股里面所以连动都不能动那过往是这样子就是可能一个东西在那边喷喷喷那有时候会出现一些回档有时候会去踩一些均线可能我就会去调节去减骂然后或甚至我不一定是想把它卖掉因为在过程之中我可能一直注意到有新的题材嘛那我要去买新的题材我是习惯满苍恨那一种人所以我就必须要卖东西去买也就是说我不是不看到它我就是需要把它卖出来因为我东西要花钱嘛我又没有办法
把它从天上掉钱下来那所以其实过往呢去报一些波段虽然理论上在过去一阵子已经是比之前更好就是你已经比较可以去吃到那种大型的波段可是在过程之中你就会一直慢慢去做一些减码跟调节那这当然又要有坏了就是坏的部分就是有时候你注意到一些那种超级大鱼你没有用全仓去把它吃完那好的部分就是有时候你减码的东西它后来就证实它真的只是一个小波段然后就没有吃到
但绝大多数的想法应该都跟我是比较类似如果可以稍微轻松一点赚钱谁不想要轻松一点赚钱那也因为东西又被关在储置里面是完全是动弹不得那甚至那时候有些自己手上的部位是它进储置的时候你大概只要丢个可能30张50张它本来量还蛮大的可是它进储置之后30张50张你可能就可以直接把它灌到跌停所以你根本就是完全不可能去动它然后它就这样一直上去上到储置后才有办法给你去做调节
那所以自己的5月就算是打出一个非常暴利的报酬那自己回头看会觉得那时候4月已经觉得非常不可思议了然后没有想到到5月号这样子一波所以真的只有感恩赞叹的心情那今年年初到现在也算是切了蛮多的题材了一开始是做卫星相关然后后来有切一些载版再来做一些玻璃机版的东西这都差不多在第一季左右的时候就完成了也就是后来我就差不多去解码再换到新的东西
那进入到第二季就开始去做一些涨价的题材像是被动元件或者说比较近期的功率元件等等的那在美股这边动作就比较少一点因为一般来说都是用较为长期的心态去看它那最近一个比较大的调动就是因为需要去挪钱出来买SpaceX那所以就会把一些手上持股可能表现比较不好的就把它卖一卖然后以及TESLA也卖一卖因为觉得反正我最主要去买TESLA
是为了押住马斯克那现在有一个SpaceX可以押住那所以呢就去调节出一部分的资金去买了SpaceX那再来比较大的亮点就是算是有押到整个CPU然后在ASIC的话Marvel也是有押到但是呢最近这几档都稍微都有去做一点调节为什么因为开始注意到美股的走势蛮分化的啦那一般在台股这边就是可能转弱的东西我就会把它卖掉那可是美股呢转弱的东西
我还蛮喜欢去接刀的所以就是看到了可能像是一些掉下的科学巨头那他们现在可能落到一个我觉得蛮不错的价位或是一些蛮大的均线那所以就有去把一些相对强势的东西砍一点出来然后再换到这些比较弱的东西那再来就是在软体的持股也有去做一些调整其实我自己本来心中是觉得像Planter这种估值超高的东西还有机会去往前冲就是一般这种大家最不相信觉得贵到不可思议
那甚至很多人想上去放空的东西呢它就会持续的领头下去但看起来呢在过去一阵子它的表现是相对的比较疲弱一点那在整个Portfolio里面走得比较好像是Crowstrike那好的东西就持续有在去点它那比较没有那么好的东西呢也是不会到要需要去减码但是就不会再去做额外的一个加码是目前用这样的态度去看那自己的心中的一个剧本是认为说
在美股这边是相对的难做一点那我还是相信后面一定是要转进去应用层面的一些表现所以像巨头应该要有一些机会那特别我比较喜欢的会是Google因为Google它现在在降本真效方面算是做得非常好不管是自己的晶片开发或是一些Portfolio的配置在模型的各种应用层面上其实我觉得它把公司调整到一个蛮好的状态那所以目前
虽然科技巨头表现是没有这么好但我还是会觉得可能可以往这边去做一个压住那苹果的话呢是我相信在Edge端之后它有机会会是一个持续维持领导地位的公司虽然可能在过去一阵子大家比较不喜欢它那认为说它在AI没有布局或什么的但是像我们自己满手都还是苹果的产品那所以就还是会相信说这家公司是有机会会为我们带来一些惊喜那只是一直没有找到
比较合适的切入点我自己会觉得说可能等到它稍微转强一点像礼拜五有注意到已经跌深的像微软或是说苹果他们反而是在大家很不好的时候他们就跳起来那如果说在接下来你注意到他们持续上去的话那我就有可能会把一些前移移到这些地方来所以以美国来说它的表现是跟台股比起来我觉得差蛮多的那还是相信说后面是有机会了因为一般台股跟美股市场特别是我们节目也这么多年的
那过去我们的经验就是会轮来轮去有时候大家那边狂骂美股很烂的时候后来美股就给你惊喜那反之一统大家觉得台股不好的时候后来台股有时候就会给你一些惊喜那所以就还是持续的去做该有的一些布局那整个上半年目前看下来是非常的满意虽然在过去的一个礼拜也算是遭受到了蛮大的一个重击按照我自己的尽职的表现来说
很快就会把六月的东西给赔掉那四五月要赔掉就老实讲应该是还蛮困难的因为已经直接再拉出一个档次了所以按我的看法会认为说特别是有蛮多的部位其实都已经是处于一个相对低成本当然相对低成本不代表说它一直跌你就不用去处分它不用去动它但一般来讲你真的会比较耐心你会比较可以怎么样在卡到好的位置的一个状况之下就会持续更大的一个波段位置没有卡好
就在一个波段的短线高点很多时候它往下跌的时候你就会觉得受不了就想把它砍掉所以就会觉得说反正且站且走慢慢的观察下去那也希望大家在接下来的下半年也可以表现得蛮不错虽然我自己目前的态度会比较偏向是中心我还是觉得说今年会是一个多头年但是因为上半年真的太夸张了你很难去想象后面还可以更夸张但我相信我四月一定也讲过类似的话就是四月好的不可思议
很难想象后面可以更好就后来有一个更好的五月那六月一开始也都非常好但是在六月的下半之后就开始有一点那种业力引爆的感觉所以整体来说是这样那也希望大家在接下来的半年可以弄出一个令你满意的半年不管它是可能在工作在家庭或是事业上不管你想要专注的东西是什么还是投资希望大家都可以去达成自己要的一个目标大概这样子好那接下来
我们就来回归一下最近的盘面稍微讲一下自己的一个看法那老实说呢我自己本身是以为大概在礼拜三礼拜四左右就会开始看到盘面出现一些反弹特别是其实在礼拜四的差不多过了十一点半十二点之后你就注意到说台股有很多中小型其实它是在拉尾盘然后一些过去的强势股也都在拉尾盘所以本来我以为差不多到这个地方就结束然后我就已经有持续的把钱打进去
然后在礼拜五的时候早上是先杀然后杀完之后到中午的时候有一些相对强势的股票有试着站回去我就被套在一个他妈日内的高点因为我就觉得说这个地方应该就是要反攻因为前面特别是在九点多还十点的时候有看到国具的期货直接跑去跌停这什么意思就它的现股根本就还没有要去跌停可是期货先跌停一定是那一堆杠杆杠超大的要自杀了所以就会认为说
有可能筹码到这边已经洗的差不多了然后在外加说有注意到说台肢有一段突然间的击杀那个我认为也是一些就是杠杆杠到最大的人他们可能出现了一些必须要自断或甚至是已经要看到断头的压力所以赶快把东西给处分掉比如说恐慌大逃杀看到这个东西就会觉得说那我接下来就是等到有东西开始要站回去的时候我就要再把它部位打进去但我现在心中的感受是
我觉得好像有一点打得太快也就是说如果那时候反弹真的是出在礼拜四的话我会觉得说整体的形态是涨得还蛮有机会就是在接下来很快又会再跑回去新高可是因为在额外多了一个礼拜五然后这一根算是蛮大的然后你就注意到说其实过往的一些热门族群的股票他们在礼拜五的时候有蛮多是直接跑到季线下面去了那按照我们自己的经验就是这些跑到
季线下面的东西当然你说反弹有没有看到反弹还是会看到因为杀很快的东西就是后面会出一些反弹那可是呢就是一般如果说你一次就跌到季线以下的话呢就是蛮高几率因为它可能后面扣底就会转成是负的嘛那所以在反弹的过程之中摸到一些可能比较大的均线就是注意到一堆那种美红干的就是开始因为它解套了所以就赶快把东西丢掉所以就导致说它后来要上去的一个几率
或者说它要上去的力道都会变得蛮小的那也就是说在我的角度会认为说如果它本来在礼拜三礼拜四就继续上去的话其实市场的广度都还蛮大的可是因为有蛮多东西就直接摔破了所以市场的广度就变小了就可能会集中在一些真的还蛮强势的东西有机会会后面又再跑上去可是呢就是那些只要去杀太深的一般可能就是在反弹之后你就会注意到它会再次软掉
所以呢这边可能是要稍微比较小心的点了啦
它直接一路往下灌然后灌爆季线的但我是认为说就有时候不要太急就是在那种最恐慌的时候把它不会砍掉因为很多时候你回头看就会发现你砍在最低点可是一般这种真的回到超级深然后已经跑到你就想嘛就纪线就是60天平均成本啦也就是说过去60天买的人全部都套牢了嘛那这些东西在反弹之后呢就是有机会会有蛮大的卖压也就是它可能也不一定上得去它只是让你少赔一点或者说
让你可能未实现的获利再多跑回来一点点但是后面要再继续的快速进攻一般来说几率是偏低几率是偏低所以就是说多了这一两根下去我会觉得有些东西可能就开始走位啦当然这个可能是直接分析给一些人听因为对我来讲我目前手上的东西都还是属于那种比较强势的东西反正就是那些涨价元件嘛那他们基本上都离纪线上还蛮远的
可是我注意到就是过去的一些热门族群他们是直接跑到纪线下面去了那这个就是大家自己要稍微注意一下因为一般跑到纪线下面的东西市场上的做多意愿就会偏低啦除非他突然间有一个就是前面大家都没有听过的好消息丢出来不然这就是我们讲的做坏掉了就被丢坏掉了他后面要再爬回去就是相对的困难一点那在过去一阵子当然大家就开始讨论说这一波的修正到底在跌什么他当然有可能是跟
就是差不多6月5号就我深圳那附近的时候不是也是一个超大的沙盘吗跌满深的然后后来就高速的拉回来在6月15号左右就开始一路在往上喷了嘛但也有可能是像这样子的一个状态啦但就是说因为一般在市场下跌的时候你就会知道有很多的坏消息丢出来那有些可能就是比较夸张一点有些就是比较唬难一点但反正只要盘不好就一定有一些坏消息那一般我们不会太在意
那一些乱丢出来的坏消息可是有一些可能比较关键的我们会稍微看一下那据来说像最近有个说法就是说现在可能是一些主权基金啊退休金因为他们在过去的一季表现非常好就跟你各位或是跟我一样大家可能都在科技股赚到蛮多钱的那他们就必须要去执行就是每个季度的一个rebalance这什么意思呢就他portfolio里面可能有东西是喷了30%那有东西呢可能是往下跌的有东西可能是在横盘
那相对来说那些涨比较多的是不是就是在他的净值的占比会变高那因为他们是走一个比较保守的策略所以呢他们就会选择去把这些变高变贵的东西去做一个比较那种机械式的减码那减码出来的钱呢就是去买那些下来可能已经是跑到他在净值里面百分比是比较低的东西去做一些加码那这个我们把它称为是一个rebalance那我觉得是
蛮合理的一个说法就是因为可能在过去的科技股票涨很多所以导致就是你注意到说有蛮多喷很多的东西然后被大量的提款这个可能就是一种就是市场那些大资金太弱流强的一个结果那当然也有些人说是因为美伊战争这边又什么再一次去轰人家那我稍微的看了一下其实现在有蛮多所谓的革命卫队在做什么事情的新闻那个都偏向是假消息
就是你真的去认真查之后就会知道说它的假消息或者说它其实没有一些外电的来源之类的那就算是有外电的来源可能是一些那种野鸡报导之类的那我觉得这一点呢其实非常简单去做判断就直接看油价就好就油价已经跌到七八十块左右所以就像那时候跟大家分享因为那时候QA有一个听众问我说战争怎么看吗我就说其实基本上当你注意到说他在丢一些东西然后市场都已经没有反应的时候我们会去相信市场的一个判断
那当你已经注意到说油价已经掉到这个位阶其实应该就已经在一个善后的阶段就是说过去的那个face已经结束了当然我们不排除就是川普我们可能再搞一个新的face出来那是有机会只是呢就是美意战争这个事情应该不会是市场这一波驱动它掉下去的一个主因因为你直接看油价就已经是像是open book一样了那再有些人讲说会不会是升息的可能性升息的可能性
那有些人讲说他最主要是锁定核心CPI这是一个比较主流的说法那有些人讲说他其实会看整体外面的环境是怎么样也会去做一些调动那像油价可能很高的时候大家就会担心嘛油价现在是相对低下来可能就还好可是大家同时也注意到说因为AI导致像大家看到那个美光的财报超级好嘛那现在看到苹果也受不了要涨价了所以呢有没有可能要去压制这些所谓的通膨的状态
即便大老板本人川普是说他喜欢通膨没有问题然后去做什么很大幅度的升息什么一年内要赶快再多拉个什么三次以上之类这个我觉得也是属于几率偏低因为第一个就大老板本身他应该是不会想要这样的事情发生然后再来第二个是其实现在的这些价格我们看到很多那种涨价狂潮什么他其实比较集中在
像是Data Center这边因为这些大型的客户对他来讲像以下一个AI Server来说他可能在记忆体这边的Bomb Cost就已经是跑30%去了他成本有30%的记忆体可是他们还是买得很高兴因为对这些巨头来讲他们太有钱了反映在消费端这边的话可能就是有一些需求被破坏掉也就是说当价格涨到某个位置这电脑还可以用GTA是可能11月才出10月才出
我现在不用急着换电脑所以大家会选择去遞延自己的消费然后外加其实过去的盘面很好大家都想要把钱全部打进市场里面所以我会觉得说他比较不会是那种可能超大范围的你会注意到这种涨价影响到大家的生活反而是可能它是集中在一些小范围内的当然不排除后面会把它扩散出来然后特别是这一波的财富效应让很多人在股票市场赚到钱那一般我们有个说法是这样子
就是当财富效应正在发生扩张的时候也就是可能盘面狂涨的时候那大家会想说理论上不是每个人都变有钱了吗特别像美国就是几乎大家都上车因为他们有什么401K什么的那所以应该你变有钱你就想多花钱可是其实不一定是这样子因为在盘很好的时候大家会认为说我现在不把钱丢进去市场里面的话我的机会成本太高了所以大家都会持续往市场里面丢那会等到什么时候呢
就等到说可能盘面开始震荡开始会修理人那修理人的频率开始变得很高或者说开始也会有很多的那种袋鼠盘的现象产生的时候然后大家会产生一个想法像我最近就开始产生这种想法马的赔掉不如花掉那这时候可能就会去把一些股票的资产拉出来然后可能去买别的东西所以我觉得说可能一些消费是在那个时候才会发生所以等到那个时候我们再来观察说现在这些涨价到底会不会去
非常大幅度的冲击消费它会比较准一点点就是说需求到底会被破坏掉那时候看会相对的准一点点那包含说像台湾的一些房地产市场我觉得也是因为过去很多草房的资金家也都丢进去股票市场里面你应该都在报导上面看到什么四代同堂力都有的没有的每个人都在借钱对那可能就是要等到市场稍微告一个段落之后你就会注意到说这些钱有些我自己猜测它就会回流回去房地产或是跑去买其他东西
那应该是后面会有觉得看到的一个情形反正总之会认为说它没有太大的一个压力需要在短期内去做一个急迫的升息我就觉得这个应该也不是最主要的一个核心的理由所以纵观下来我觉得不是战争我觉得也不是什么美银报告说什么快速升息我觉得应该rebalance那个就你要去找一个理由的话这个东西是比较接近的那至于市场上其他人讲的那什么AI泡沫什么的
这个你就听听就好因为那些AI泡沫论者从20232024一路讲讲到现在他总会有对的一天你懂吗他总会有一天被他讲中可是他错过的是这么大端的一个东西所以我觉得那个就稍微看看就好但我最近确实是有跟自己的身边朋友讨论到一件事情就是这些科技巨头的股东会不会开始有一些坐不住了为什么因为你看到说像美光的毛利率80几他搞不好在接下来几个Q
甚至会上到90几就是暴利他现在随便卖随便赚那这些科技巨头他们是付钱的支出方他们也是去做出应用然后真的去实践AI导入大家的生活之中去改变大家生活的那一方可是他们的股价的表现非常不好他们的cash flow有些可能甚至要跑到负值去了所以在这样的一个状况之下是不是就是会开始有一些检讨的声音出现这个是有机会
虽然可能在Deep Seek那一波就有类似在市场上有这样子一个讨论后面因为Deep Seek它并没有烧得很大它是造成一些改变没错就是大家把一些注意力可能发到开源模型去可是它那时候并没有造成这么大的一个讨论那看这波有没有机会去酝酿出这样子一个讨论就是这些巨头的股东会不会开始坐不住然后觉得说这些钱都付给这些零组件厂商被它赚走了我们全部买得这么急可是成效不一定有看到
那我们是不是还是要推得这么快就是后面去注意一下有没有这样的论述跑出来的可能性我觉得可能盘面在继续转叉的时候就会有这样子论述跑出来的可能性那到时候再来看会不会对市场的sentiment造成一些影响那目前我们看下来会觉得我特别是我最近有少了一些这些巨头们他们去deploy AI伺服器的数字他们在台系供应链的拉货
目前看起来是没有什么太多的问题那当然至于是不是要去杀估值什么这个我就没有办法去做太多判断可是呢纯旧产业层面来看呢其实有蛮多事情都还在酝酿中所以我觉得比较像是一个市场信心的短期内的丢失啊就跟过去几波的一些修正可能是比较类似像是2026年的三月的那一波也是震荡在修嘛然后再来就是可能六月初的那一波我觉得现在是比较偏向这样的一个情形
但是呢因为真的已经有一些东西开始出现它是跑到季线下面去的所以还是要自己稍微的注意一下因为你可能去看到大盘的位置还是蛮不错的还是有机会踩到大军线继续进攻那可是你自己手上不会如果开始发现说它站不回去的话这个要稍微的注意一下即便它可能是AI相关的东西那即便它可能是市场上一些大题材但资金没有在这边那它就是可能会比较难上去
也就是说你可能掉到季线的部分是一个以价值投资来讲相对好的买点但你就有机会要等有机会要等这个可能是稍微要看一下的那接下来我们来稍微的聊一下苹果的涨价话题那苹果终于是撑不住了也在记忆体的价格高涨的状况之下拿他们去上修了我们也就是看到说像是MacBook或是一些产品线的价格拉了大概十几到二十%左右的一个位置那在这个时间涨价还蛮有趣的
就本来可能大家想象会它跟着一些新品去做涨价可能是还OK但它选择在这个时间某个程度上去涨了一些像是可以把称为是旧品的东西那是不是代表说它在新品的涨价也先去做了一个预热就这个东西后面丢出来也会是一个就是可能会让一些人吓到的价格但是让一些人吓到的价格不代表会让果粉吓到这个非常重要所以有时候在市场里面去讨论一些话题的时候
我觉得首先你要先定义出你的客人是谁然后再来就是你去参与一些讨论的时候你要知道对方是不是跟你是同一类型的人就是我们有时候会知道说反正河水不犯井水大家其实是在不同圈子的东西有些人去买苹果的他们把它称为是臭盘子那这些臭盘子其实他一辈子也不会跑去买安卓那安卓的一辈子可能也不会跑去买苹果所以你们在那边互干了半天其实大家是彼此不影响对方
只有在一些特殊的场域上像在游戏业界很常会因为外面的一些DI的言论然后去改变游戏的设计可是他们最终也开始发现说其实很多在对这些游戏的所谓的多元价值去做批评的人他们本身不太会买游戏那蛮多游戏商注意到这件事情了所以他们知道说他真的要去巩固了其实是他的客人而不是那一些可能就是在场外喊烧的人
所以一样的道理你说苹果这个涨价数字高不高以我自己身为果粉的角度来说我觉得一定是高达但你说会不会继续买就还是会买听到这边你不是果粉的就是说妈点这个臭盘子可是果粉的听到这边就觉得说不就是这样子其实老实讲你说记忆体的mark up价格苹果它确实是在记忆体这边是做了蛮多的涨价就是说它不可能的很老实去反映它原物料的价格我随便举计
假计记忆体它多插一条成本假计是10块好了从10块变20块的成本它不可能它就是在售价上面加你10块因为它有它的毛利要顾然后再来就是说也有品牌价值这一点这点可能就是说一样我刚才前面讲的精髓不犯河水不懂的人就是永远不会懂懂的人其实也不需要去做太多的说明但我们这边还是稍微说明一下简单来讲就是说一个爱马仕的包包它在上面去多给你几个锚钉
或是什么多缝个几块皮革它可以多卖你几千上万可是如果你今天是一个不知道花枪北那边假设有在弄包包的话这个包包你额外再打一个锚钉它可能就是成本价然后再额外价一点点就这样就给你可是你会说所以买花枪北的包包就比爱马仕划算OK对这可能是一个比较极端的举例那一样见仁见智以刚才手机的角度来讲
我还是不会去买可能就是中系手机之类的我就是会买苹果可是以包包角度来讲我还真的可能会去买那个花枪北的包包所以一样的道理就是这个东西它是比较属于一个见仁见智的东西所以你在网上看到很多吵架他们其实是一个就是大家互相在轻谈你们吵了半天其实你们彼此的生活都还是会去走各自的路你觉得对方是白痴对方刚好也觉得你是白痴
可是要注意的点是这个东西会不会真的影响到实际上会买这个产品的人这个才是可能在各种话题里面要讨论的一个重点其实这种东西也不用去做太多网络的辩驳最后面直接看销量就好就类似说我们去做股票上场投资你不用去讨论太多那种战争的话题大概知道就好最后面直接看油价就好因为那就是一个结果那样的道理如果我们今天注意到
销量的数字是跑得不好的话那就反映了它这个价格可能就是不被它本来的消费者接受然后再来就是可能新的想加入的消费者也会因为这样子会却步所以才反映到你的销量是不好那时候可能就等到用销量去做一个佐证就最好了所以像前阵子不是蛮多人也是整天在凑苹果说什么你跟不到AI时代你表现不好吗可是太香了因为那时候以各家其他手机OEM
他们为了要去反映记忆体的涨价严格上来说不是说什么他们先涨价他们是比较黑心应该是说苹果的价格粘性一般来说都是比较高它提早就已经在上面它毛利是比较肥所以它不用这么快去反映那一些中系的OEM或者一些什么韩系或者说美系的手机可能没有办法它没有这么大的一个护城额它立刻去做反映所以在当下的一个相对之下大家觉得苹果是相对划算的所以导致说苹果那时候
冲一波销量出来可是苹果如果现在它也跟进了涨价我们就要去看后续的一个销量的表现是怎么样然后再判断说这个涨价到底消费者吃不吃得下去有时候你觉得吃不下去可能只是你不是它的受众所以这个可能要理性一点去看会比较准一点但一般来说我们看到这种涨价的东西会是抱一个比较正向的讯号不然说像是供应链的这边涨价
除非说你看到这个涨价是客户已经拒绝去吃了你才会去担心以目前在AI端来说我觉得蛮多做供应链的其实我们的胃口也被养坏掉就会觉得说这些涨价怎么你看到那种波线布或是你看到什么Q布然后或者是各式各样的原物料零组件被动原件记忆体你知道你怎么涨这些亏据头都会买单所以大家已经是上司了那种风险意识反正怎么涨他们都会买单只要是涨价就等于是好消息
但消费端这边其实是要比较小心一点的因为它最终要面对的是普罗百姓普罗百姓不是他妈每个都有在做股票炒房地产或者说他升官发财赚很多钱有蛮多可能是他就是拿一个差不多的薪水所以一个东西贵了20%贵了30%它不像那些科技巨头反正无条件接受我就是要去参与AI竞争我一定要买那消费者可能有些就真的就不买了所以他就会直接很血淋淋的反映在他的销量上面
所以这可能也解释了就是为什么你看到一些供应链的股票你听到涨价基本上就等于说一定会往上涨可是为什么苹果的涨价刚出来之间跌当然它隔一天就继续涨所以这个还比较我觉得neutral你还没有办法现在要去做判断还是要观察一下因为其实我觉得大家应该都很想问这个问题就是现在终端消费市场到底有没有利器现在比较难判断的主因是因为过去的股票涨很多大家理论上都相信财富效应会蔓延出来
会买各种东西可是因为就是股票一直在涨所以大家不愿意出来那出来之后说不定你还会看到一个消费的龙景这个是有机会看到所以到时候那些涨价不一定会对这些消费者造成一些压力这是有机会的所以这个我们还是得稍微的看一下才可以去做一个比较全面的判断所以就大概评论一下这件事情快速的总结一下其实去做Markup这件事情它并不是苹果的一个专利
只是苹果它一般就是可能毛利看起来特别厚然后它的价格是特别黏这是真的可是其他人其实也都会去做类似的事情唯一一个比较老实在反映价格是中细的OEM可是中细的OEM为什么会老实反映价格因为他们就是用低价廉价去做强势战的动作所以他当然会用一个可能相对便宜的价格Markup比较少的价格去对市场做贩售可是你会去买那个也不一定你会去买那个
除非可能经济真的不好开始出现消费降级像之前在中国这边是看到说他们那种整形机卖的特别可能经济比较差的时候才会有大家往那个方向去挤的一个样态可是如果经济好的时候其实蛮多人都是很乐意去吃Markup所以我们要看一下说这一波记忆体造成的一个影响那他目前看起来我觉得对记忆体厂商来说压力不会太大因为只要这些巨头持续买单的话消费性不好
你看美光直接把消费性放掉它根本也没差了那可是如果说怎么说就是在消费性这边你开始注意到一些收手因为这些人你要知道其实在科技巨头上班的这些人或者是说炒股票赚钱这些人他们最终他们其实也都是消费者那如果说外面的世界开始产生一些影响价格开始高涨然后导致大家不愿意去做一些支出的话其实最终都会影响到就是最核心的那些
甚至是跟AI有关的需求只是这个像他讲我觉得是有点太早但趁着波反而下外面也都是鬼故事就一次把所有的鬼故事讨论完我觉得大家就之后会可以去感受到之前跟大家分享为什么我会说有时候在修正的时候那个故事你知道就好可是你不要太认真去看待它因为你会发现每一次就是以过去来讲其实波段往下跌5到8%的那个机会是蛮多的吧以大盘的角度来讲每次跌的时候
那些鬼故事你在之后新高的时候你回头看其实真的就没有半个人在讨论所以它有点像的时候反正不好的时候会被拿出来当一个谈资但我们简单的去做一个review那目前对于产业的角度还是跟过去一样就是我们没有注意到有太多显著的立刻会反转的一个可能性但是呢确实是可能因为一些资金面的驱动导致一下盘面出现一些不一样的状况那些rebalance可能会trigger一些事情
那一些股票可能跌到季线以下的可能开始假设因为我们现在不知道说台面下的这些贷款到底大家跌的多高我们只知道很高可是我们不知道跌在哪里我们不知道他们什么时候会开始感受到压力要丢会不会触发一个连锁反应这个还是要稍微小心一点那比较容易去保护自己的方式就是你去稍微注意一下形态那个均线如果开始拉平开始做一个头的虽然这边讲起来会有点
有些人会觉得说这个感觉像是现先的可是我们真的会参考这些东西就是价格的一些变化其实还是蛮重要的你不可以完全说我就是fundamental然后一个东西一直爆爆爆因为很多时候那个价格变化会跑在前面然后类似说大家记不记得那时候在去年关税地均要开始出全的时候那时候三月不是美股整天在往下跌就整天跌然后没有消息然后跌到后来我那时候的说法是说就是我要找一个还OK的反弹我要有尊严的出去
那后来就是有去做一些调整然后于是我们后面看到这个关税地均的事情所以当一个下跌假设它持续的蔓延持续的发生的话有时候消息它其实是跟在后面的这个可能大家自己也是要稍微的注意一下所以大概这样但以现阶段来说我相信绝大多数人它就是一个获利回吐的问题而已只是说吐到什么时候大家会受不了然后开始去乱卖这我们不知道但一般来讲如果它不小心的回到太深那接着反弹又弹不上去的话
就会有乱卖的一个情形这可能自己要稍微注意一下就是自己的现金水位你有东西要买的要稍微先腾点钱出来大概这样好 接下来我们来进入QA的部分因为在QA这边我们平常是礼拜三走Spotify然后礼拜六走Apple可是像我刚刚限动发的就是现在Apple的它的QA不知道什么都没有再更新了所以在未来的一阵子我们都先三六都维持在Spotify这边
我们先尽量都在Spotify这边如果后面有一些变动再来跟大家说再来这样子第一位阿金老公好有件事想听您的看法前阵子因为目睹前方车祸机车倒地第一时间虽然想伸出援手但因为顾虑后续麻烦而选择冷漠的绕开现在心里有些后悔跟纠结那想问这种两难状况下有没有更圆融的做法谢谢好像没有
就是你要么就停下来帮忙要么就是你就离开然后可能打个电话可是就算你不打电话应该也是很多人会打电话因为他就是在路中间所以就是二选一那我自己的话会怎么样做一般来讲我应该是会停下来的那一个但如果我今天车上假设有载我小孩又在高速公路的话我应该是会绕开然后再报警所以我觉得你也不用对自己可能给太大的压力
说好像你很冷漠的绕开不是啊就是说你可能你也没注意到嘛或者你当下没有反应过来嘛那个不是你的错啊不要再想太多了下面一位Tim MK哥您好小弟最近工作刚满五年瞎在MTK过得不是很开心想换工作但是又有点不晓得要追求钱还是自由您的话肯定是选钱吧不过您28岁的时候也是一样吗爱您PS即使发歌
前阵子涨停的超多根但是因为公司的制度周遭的人跟我大多数在三月就卖了这个听起来是一个非常令人难受的故事啊那刚刚前面讲到MTK我不小心笑出来的原因不是因为就是我想要嘲笑你是因为因为我身边真的蛮多朋友在MTK啊那我跟MTK也有一点渊源啊就是去他们公司也参访过然后又有去那边演讲过那所以算是认识了蛮多那边的人我是感觉他们看起来都还蛮快乐的啊
虽然我讲这个时候我相信他们很多心中一定是有一些OS要讲大M产薯条快乐产薯条快乐赚钱那以一个怎么讲年轻人的角度来讲呢我会认为说赚钱是比较重要的啦就是我会很难去想象说工作本身是会非常快乐的只要这个工作本身它不会让我觉得心理压力很大每天看到老板我就想他妈给他一个走级或者说
每天想到上班我就很忧郁的话那我会认为说反正上班本身我这样问一个话啦谁是没事去上班的你各位谁是没事去上班的除非说你是骂五六十岁然后第二层在家真的不知道干嘛才跑去嘛觉得多数你上班你不就是为了去赚点钱吗所以钱很多的话稍微的有点不快乐我觉得也是OK的啦就是他应该是一个可以接受的trade off
没有问题那所以在我的角度会觉得如果你今天钱不够多的话MTK是很多人梦寐以求可以去的地方那甚至呢MTK在这几年他算是某种程度上的跳板吧对不对蛮多会跳去的你知道那几家就是跳到人家都觉得说靠北整天挖我的人那你要想你没有这个经验你也很难跳到那几个公司去嘛我们就不要去点名了但反正总之
他是一个应该蛮多人称线的地方那这个东西我觉得他们在各种工作室嘛你去问医生医生家每个人都在跟你干说他们的工作压力大然后钱少可是你在局务多数人眼中是你们就是台湾最有钱的人啦就以领薪水来讲那很多时候你觉得你自己没有钱是因为你去比较的对象是资产阶级资产阶级是另外一回事的那个是常年的累积或者说有时候要有一点那种时事的背景在
要有一点胆识或怎么样的那薪水就是反正不败嘛怎么样都可以拿到钱那所以我觉得MTK已经是一个大家都很羡慕的地方除非你真的是极度的难受那你去退而求其实找一个薪水没这么高但至少你心情好一点的地方去也好但我要跟你讲一个很现实的东西是你会以为说你去别的地方会很好说不定你跑到别的地方吃你一样有不满的东西然后钱又没有给够所以那个不爽指数
反而会跑到更高这个是有机会是这样子的要稍微注意一下好下面一位Mark梦工老公安安刚从韩国打工度假回来不知道要找什么工作救命那不过真味食堂真的好好吃可惜Lisa现在不来韩国了好想见到老公全家人许愿可以找到一个躺平的工作爱您不知道现在有什么工作是可以躺平的
去当那种血牛之类的吧现在有这种工作嘛就以前会听我爸说什么他年轻没有钱的时候曾经当过血牛就是去参与人家什么药物实验啊或是去什么捐血换钱现在应该没有这种东西啊但他那个看起来就是躺着就可以工作啊或许可以往这个方向去思考看看然后你不是从韩国打工度假回来的我去韩国也遇不到你啊下面一位York嘿嘿梦工去家以前没有买股票的时候
花钱如流水但是开始投资股票的时候随着资产翻倍成长反而越来越省因为总有种今天省下来的一块钱未来会变成两块那想问梦工有过一样的感受吗这个就是我刚才前面讲的嘛就是当今天股票一直在上涨的时候其实真的没有人就是你在股票会做的人会想要把钱拿出来花因为你会觉得我的每一笔钱现在都可以赚到更多钱你甚至会非常的
反感任何要让你踩煞车的一个行为据来说在2020因为那时候我们有孩子嘛然后老婆说那我们来买一间房好了当时我是很不爽我觉得这个盘这么好怎么可以现在去买房子然后那时候觉得说其实后来看是一个蛮不错的决定你的心态会稍微的稳一点因为你不是所有的钱都在那种股票里面你有些可能放到别的地方去所以有时候赛翁司马炎之非福如果有一些必要的支出
就还是把它花下去吧但是你这样的心态是每个人都有而且其实跟你的资产高低没有关系就是说你可能在百万千万的时候你有这个想法那我告诉你你破亿你实亿你应该都还是会有一样的想法因为我们身边的人都有类似的想法就是他们都会想要有更多钱可以丢到市场里面从来没有听过说什么我这样赚够了然后我就是想要把所有钱都拿出来我不要再参与市场就是每个人都是不够的甚至像之前
有一个身边的朋友跟我分享过他在业界也算是待了蛮久他说他只有看过一个是真的赚到他的设定目标之后然后就退休把所有的东西拿去买abond就是拿去买债券然后接着就是领那个债券的利息再也不碰股票我说连0050都不买都不买就是直接完全的退出其实很多人都讲过说我到什么地方我就要退出我就要赔家人但他看下来就只有那一个人这样
以我自己的角度来看因为他算是比我资深的人我自己的角度是我没有看过任何一个就是有喊停的人就基本上是停不下了所以自己还是要去找到一个平衡特别是我还是在节目上常常呼吁大家要善待自己的家人因为你在股票市场你一天的震荡可能就是你家人他跟你许愿说到某个东西你的震荡是远超过那个东西然后你一直不想要买给他但是不是每个人
都会一辈子在你身边陪着你所以这个还是自己要稍微小心一下那下面一位万事不绝对孟公你好我是马来西亚的听众从EP300多开始到现在你的好多无意间的话都会让我好几次shock的恍然大悟非常感谢遇到这么好的节目也谢谢你祝你全家身体健康开开心心那我们希望这个马来西亚的朋友可以快乐健康平安下面一位DKDKDK93
孟公大好上次留言没有念到才说是不是要直上五万不等人的然后这次直接修正一波QQ我有个住在台北从来没有开过车的老同学为了接送可爱的女儿上幼稚园人生第一台车要直上宝马啦哈哈那祝福内湖数据长行车平安开车大吉那我们希望他千辛车快乐那下面一位有点常在念一下
宾美式OO孟公大好Lisa和秋口诺雅安哥好听了五年第一次留言过去曾经有很多想说的话真的要留言的时候又不知道从何说起早期的我是完全听不懂中间的气氛仔那最近开始懂产业而已还是听不太懂太细的内容我和孟公大同乡孟公大说话时的尾音常常会有客家腔让人觉得好熟悉早期孟公大在0050还没有分拆时
停到006208相对便宜当时的我有买目前也翻一倍了那我的工作忙碌也很孤独听节目好像变成唯一的类社交活动那至少没有和世界脱节而且许多听众的留言也都会给我生活中的思考谢谢各位兄弟姐妹们那最后希望孟公去改用客家话对即将过生日的我说那四个字你还没给牌谢谢我为什么又要讲奇怪的话
就讲赏云快乐就讲生日快乐就为什么要乱接话好了那前面讲的客家腔其实我觉得我客家腔没有很重因为客家腔很好认就是会说或是哪那个东西好贵太贵了这个就是可能客家人讲话会这样子或是说油脂袋我们不会讲塑料袋我们讲油脂袋或者说一个人整天躺在那里就说
所以那你一听就知道我自己本身算是一半一半我妈妈是闽南人花莲的闽南人可能就会这样有综合调就是没有真的很客家但是其实我们家族里面蛮多人讲话就是像我刚才前面讲的那样然后有很多的客家腔所以偶尔还是会不小心露出一点客家腔我觉得蛮有趣的下面一位
Chan孟公安安可以问问美国人到底会不会做股票吗其实现阶段不只是想问美国人我想问台湾人会不会做股票像觉得说礼拜四的尾班在那边拉其实礼拜五有些东西可以直接进攻确实有些东西有进攻只是后来就被灌回来所以就代表说下来已经是很多人失去了勇气那再来在我刚才前面聊到说11点12点的时候其实有蛮多东西是攻回去快要往平盘的方向走我自己就跟着那边狂敲
因为这个地方其实真的可以去做一个很漂亮的下影线去反攻只是尾盘有一堆人把它丢回来我想说你们到底会不会做股票但现在讲是这样子如果下礼拜一那么它再开DG往下走我那个加码的应该有把它丢出来反正你们不要玩老子也不要玩我们要协助把这个盘砸掉所以现在就是有一种那种全面恐慌的感觉出来
一点点然后我们再来观察会怎么样下面一位山中的大宝贝梦公安请问你可以用川普便秘的声音宣布新竹周一台风驾吗也祝梦公宝贝股票射到天上去Constipated没有办法那就是希望新竹可以放假因为我看到那个好像是就在新竹吧有一个那个autobus在公车旁边直接变滑水道虽然对啊这不应该笑可是那个影片我重看了太多次
那个太经典了就很危险啊所以如果说真的这个风雨达标的话还是希望有关单位要稍微体恤一下大家以前我是非常反对台风驾的人然后后来发现说不能够这么自私我自己很喜欢工作没错只是有些人他确实是可能他家里出来就会有危险或什么我们要去在意一下这些人所以我现在就站在那个放假派然后就尽量放随便放没关系反正我前面被那个储置股关完之后我现在对股票也有新的认知了我就想说
反正我就当成我整天都被关也没有关系好了那下面一个太长跳过在下面一位Pack孟公自己可以用云霄飞车的emoji吗好久没有在节目听到有怪小的发言了那遇到下跌反而会开始期待听QA想知道孟公会不会有替在乎的人花钱比花在自己身上还甘愿的感觉那虽然自己资产提高了但觉得自己不值得那最后希望孟公可以用
猛男的语音包祝我跟女友Peggy保持愉快一起便富一代祝孟公自己一家平安健康又快乐爱您我以前会很直接的跟你说对没错就是花在自己身上不值得然后也不会花太多但自从过去两个月的这个疯狂红酒尝试之后其实我是真的有点疯狂所以我后来觉得说我可能一次就花了好几年
应该可以花在自己身上的钱但我想法是跟你一模一样就是我花在别人身上是比较开心不然说像花在老婆身上或是小孩身上但如果真的硬要选一个花在小孩身上更夸张就是你不会觉得这是一个问题你买卡包给他即便这个卡包像有些卡包已经绝版了像他很喜欢那个我不要讲因为讲的时候一堆人在跑去买就再更贵他喜欢某一个绝版的卡包然后我就会去买那个卡包给他那个卡包
其实算起来比一般卡包贵大概四五倍左右可是当你看到他收到然后在那边拆然后还会自己跟你讲说爸爸我今天可以拆两个我赶快洗澡因为学完澡可以拆两个然后我有时候他会想拗你一下说爸爸我今天表现好可不可以再多拆一个什么的你就一直想要是买这个卡包给他就即便你知道你是一个盘子可是你就还是会想要去让他开心这样所以以前人家讲什么失比受更有福我得说我在二十几岁的时候
不知道这件事情我也曾经想过说为什么要生孩子脱油瓶为什么要结婚为什么要花这种钱单身一辈子快乐一辈子这个想法我都有过但就是对有些东西可能真的年纪到才会懂类似我们刚才前面讲的话会发现说我觉得人为什么越来越沉默是因为你真的不需要跟任何人讲太多或试着去说服任何人因为当你们是不同位阶不同资产不同的家庭背景不同的家庭环境不同的配置你们真的是
有时候是没有办法对话的你现在跟人家讲讲了半天也没有用反正时间到了他懂他就是会懂如果他不会懂他一辈子跟你也没有交集所以你真的有需要说服的只有自己家庭最核心的人就大概是这样子但我完全认同你的说法下面一位good tonegat tonegat tone是什么懂神的ID是不是mk大我很好大家好恭喜你很好下面一位其实我已经快没有很好
你知道吗这样子一直跌下去心中是不好受最近不是在line上面他有一个可以回报大家状态的东西吗我看到每个说自己不平安的没有一个是风灾水灾每个都是股票跌很惨然后在那边靠摇说什么像他自己很惨希望大家可以去救他希望什么救人队可以赶快到淹水的公园里面之类的还是希望大家都在这次的豪雨里面可以平安健康股票的事情相较之下是小事
生命安全最重要下面一位SF985213谢谢梦工去感每周分享自己的生活跟市场的观点我7月5号生日可以跟我说那四个字吗生日快乐你看这样是不是皆大欢喜下面一位原住民的台语怎么念梦工好我是今年要考教征的考生在教育职场发现总有一些老师很混但他们却是正式教师而我努力的教学却还只能够当个代理教师心里满满的不平衡但庆幸
有时候努力的付出总有回报那有时候接住我情绪的不是身边的好友而是那些学生这里很灵验我也要来许愿倘若今年考上的话我将分期捐出一个月的薪水给流浪动物协会或是抽出十组黑马卡给地方男性麻烦梦工帮我做决定爱您我是觉得因为你后面那个抽奖我要帮你抽太麻烦了你就直接捐给流浪动物协会
我觉得是蛮好的然后再讲前面那一段我有一个unpopular opinion但我认为应该蛮多人会感同身受你这样子一个非常热血的想法其实是好发于就是因为你还没有真的进入到那个地方所以你会觉得说为什么有一堆废物主管失位素餐不做事然后他却可以是主管为什么有那些人他站着毛坑不拉屎为什么有些医师看起来没有医德为什么有些
什么做股票的然后像他整天在po干话整天在喊救命因为你还没有到那个地方就你到那个地方之后有时候你会发现说你可能本来是满腔热血但是你被一些学生或者说被一些学生家长或是被很多的办公室宿物给磨掉了所以你就会长得像是比较圆融的样子然后看在一些新来的人就会觉得说你很混或什么但那已经是一个就是为了生存
而长出来的样子所以如果你今天到一个环境你看到那些人是长那个样子的话你要思考的是你想不想变成那个样子因为你终究你高机率会变成那个样子你很难进去构造改革然后让大家变成像你这种满腔热血的样子对我不想要帮因为你看起来是一个新鲜人好像帮你把未来去盖上了一个这个什么叫黑暗的阴影的感觉可是社会真的就是这样子运作的
我觉得你还没有进去之前你都会觉得说里面的这些人一堆暂着毛坑不拉屎可是你进去之后你可能也变成是那样的人当然我们还是希望自己可以保有一些初心还是希望有一些好事可以发生但后来你对社会就比较不会有这么多的批判因为你开始渐渐的懂得大概是这样那下面一位Hikari梦跟我老公爱你我是玛丽莎我要祝竹南好友贤抗力赚大钱乖好爱大家希望大家都赚大钱下面一位
藤淡淡梦公去嘎我老公掰开了进来吧救救我你看这个就是应该是那个股票跌太多开始有些发病的人产生下面一位Andy5566梦公去嘎午安最近急速听你分享和林口猛男们在找有知人士一起来林口发展这是不是有力量之后回馈社区的一种方式也好奇想问梦公当生意越大也会伴随一些复杂的关系吗如果能够分享再让小弟见见识面了
那最后想请梦公老大用金牌讲师的语气跟我的老师女友说要放暑假了姐妹们又送走了可爱的一届辛苦你了那也祝梦公一家平安健康暑假也有更多的美好回忆那非常感谢各位兄弟那你前面讲的事情是不是会变复杂没错所以其实我一向都是跟大家说特别是那些创业的人有时候来QA问问题我就说我自己的经验是股东不要太复杂因为股东复杂事情就会变复杂
就会变麻烦那所以绝大多数像我自己参与的一些生意都是我可能就是里面唯一一个股东那我可能是出超过七八成的钱甚至是全资但是我只拿十二十%这个是我家喜欢的一个模式那可是我还是希望说创办人自己也要skin in the game就是你总是自己头要洗下去如果说你都是在玩别人钱的话我不能够期待你一定会百分之百认证你都会是吗所以你没有多少钱但是你愿意整个头洗下去
这种人是我比较喜欢的然后在林口目前可能我们丢的东西也是比较偏常说我自己知道这边可能需要这个东西所以就会去做这样的投资那时候会分享说就是自己身边朋友大家可能想说这个东西可以搞看看你的理由是因为因为人家刚好提到所以我就拿出来去讲这件事情但是我觉得如果真的要去执行的话它不会是可能像一些人想象的是我们先去集资然后弄一个fund然后去投这些东西这个可能我不喜欢这样的模式
它比较偏向是据一下说真的有一些屌的东西你想要来林口做或什么的我可以吃下我就直接全部自己吃了也不是说这么我不想分我朋友或什么的因为其实去投这种生意对我们身边这种做投资来讲它的投报率绝对都没有股票好了所以其实每个人想做这件事情都是有点类似像你讲的那种社会服务学习的态度去做但我还是会希望事情单纯一点所以能够我全吃的我一定是全吃可是身边可能
有些朋友会发现说这个东西我也有兴趣你想要上车一点OK那也让你上车一点但大家的心态应该有比较偏向说反正就是让创办人去搞看看看可不可以搞出什么样的东西所以其实我是很不喜欢合伙生意那自己目前可能有搞到的比较偏常是合伙生意的会像是孝楠这样可是孝楠因为我自己就是过半的所以大家连吵架都不用吵架因为你们没有人投票投的赢我所以就是变成说
我都最多钱那我就是去扛最大的风险那失败我也是去赔最多钱所以大家都不有意见那我也比较喜欢这样的一个模式就是我不喜欢说当然大家会想说什么应该都可以讨论然后可以沟通可是我的经验是就是当街人人多就是会嘴杂所以最好的方式是我当拿啤酒去你家的你要投什么生意你要做什么事情我过去支持你那孝楠比较罕见一点他算是我自己
本身是坐庄的人我其实是不希望我希望越低调然后躲起来越好那只是因为刚好说我们有找到一些非常厉害的业绩人士可以去帮我run这个东西所以我可以接受说OK 我在里面当一个坐庄的人那当然目前上车的人也都是自己的朋友就他不会是那种对外募资或什么所以我觉得就事情一定要尽量的单纯就是你尽量拿的钱就是如果已经充满了你就只拿少数几个人就好你千万不要说什么拿一堆人的钱
你要去迎合一堆人的期待一堆人的想法一堆人每个人都要给你意见或什么的你甚至会失去你本来的一个初衷或是你想要做的东西这个就会比较可惜一点所以应该会走一个简单的形式那这可能跟大家一开始听到的东西就不太一样因为一开始是人家跟我讲说可以这样的做我就直接分享出来我觉得是一个蛮好的idea就你要知道说林口这边有蛮多人他们是愿意去支持这样的东西但实际下去做应该理论上是
所有东西我能够吃我就自己吃掉那刚好身边朋友假设你有不要已经听到你说你要上车你也知道风险是什么你要来你就可以来这样子可是不会是说我要去揪人那个是我不喜欢的一个形式拜拜